today on the matt walsh show the left
has gone into spasms of
outrage because marjorie taylor green
made a holocaust analogy these are the
same people who make holocaust analogies
every time
they open their mouths but somehow we're
supposed to take their outrage seriously
this time well i don't
and i'll explain why also five headlines
including breaking news that the cova
vaccine is uh 100
effective in preventing covid in kids
do you know what else is nearly 100
effective in preventing coveting kids
their immune system
also minneapolis commemorates the
anniversary of george floyd's death with
a drive-by shooting
at his memorial site sort of appropriate
and in our daily cancellation we'll deal
with the
viral video which seeks to prove that
it's impossible
for a black person to be racist against
a white person all of that and more
today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
before the advent of policy genius if
you wanted to get life insurance
and find especially affordable life
insurance to find it quickly well there
was really
really no way to do it it was a huge
hassle but policy genius makes it a lot
easier and they have
solved this problem for you and for all
of us policy dudes makes it easy to
compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place
um why compare well you could save 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you could also
save
1300 or more per year on life insurance
by using policy unions to compare
policies
the license experts at policy dns work
for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
um they're in your corner you don't have
to worry about conflicts of interest or
anything like that
the kind of service that they provide
has earned policy genius five-star
ratings across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google and getting started is really
easy first just head to policygenius.com
figure out what kind of life insurance
coverage you want when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling for you
they make it that easy so
head to policygenius.com to get started
right now policy genius when it comes to
insurance
it's nice to get it right the rules
from the left are very clear just
because they get to do
and say certain things doesn't mean you
get to do or say the same things
and this holds true across the board for
uh in many areas but especially it's
true
for hitler and holocaust analogies as
you no doubt recall democrats and
leftists across the spectrum at every
level spent the past half decade
comparing donald trump to hitler
and his every executive action or policy
proposal to the holocaust
they invoke the nazis at every turn
reflexively accusing their political
opponents of being nazis
i've been called a nazi myself more
times than i can count
in spite of the fact that i've never
participated in any genocide of any kind
to my memory nor have i ever expressed
any allegiance to or affinity with
the nazi party there's no factual basis
for calling me a nazi or you or trump
but it was never about facts for them
when they say nazi they simply mean that
your opinions are bad in their opinion
and the nazis are bad
and therefore since you're both bad
you're the same
that's as far as the similarities have
to go in order to justify
the comparison in their minds and it's
not just with the nazis these are the
same people who will accuse you of
directly causing
hundreds of trans people to commit
suicide if you so much as state that
women don't have penises
these are people who will throw suicide
tragedy death genocide holocaust
around like their water balloons
whatever is required to land a hit on
their ideological opponents
and yet as established none of this
gives you license to do the same
they have different rules they have a
different lane that they run in
and you better stay in your own lane or
there will be hell to pay
marjorie taylor green learned that
yesterday when she uh sent out a tweet
comparing vaccine passports to the gold
star that jews were forced to wear
under the nazis green tweeted quote
vaccinated employees get a vaccination
logo just like the nazis forced jewish
people to wear a gold star
vaccine passports and mask mandates
create discrimination against unvaxed
people who trust their immune systems
to a virus that is 99 survivable
now so that was a tweet
and that is to my mind a sort of silly
comparison
overheated i am very opposed to vaccine
passports but this
isn't the comparison that i would draw
yet green's point here first of all
comparison aside
is correct it is wrong to discriminate
against unvaccinated people and vaccine
passports
are a terrible idea with all kinds of
potentially awful ramifications
whatever you think of the nazi tie-in
the analogy she draws here is utterly
par for the course
people do it all the time democrats
especially but not just them
people everywhere across the internet
are always invoking the nazis and world
war ii
and the holocaust to make their point is
that because they're anti-semites no
see if they're anti-semitic and they're
nazi sympathizers
then they would support the holocaust
and they wouldn't use it to illustrate
how evil something is
the whole point of the comparison is
that the holocaust
was bad that's the point
the constant nazi analogies are really
just the result of uh
not anti-semitism but a kind of
intellectual laziness and a lack of
imagination
nothing more sinister than that most of
the time
certainly in this case it's not sinister
it's not a big deal
it's not some great evil thing that
marjorie taylor greene has done she's
just done
what everyone on the internet is doing
every day all day all the time
in summary who cares well the left cares
they care about this hyperbolic
nazi analogy this one outraged them the
ones they make
all day every day all the time non-stop
are okay but
this one was beyond the pale marjory
taylor green's
tweet set off a day's worth and now two
days worth of
over-the-top hand-wringing outrage
condemnations
solemn conversations about the grave
threat
that marjorie taylor green poses to our
democracy
her tweet was condemned by every
democrat every media outlet even the
auschwitz
museum felt the need to chime in cable
news yesterday featured
many breathless segments like this one
with john berman on cnn listen to this
it is not only a historic it is
abhorrent it's also apparently
allowable under house minority leader
kevin mccarthy who hasn't commented on
it and refused to punish green for past
anti-semitic statements she made
wearing a mask compared to the murder of
six million
people it's so far beyond the realm of
decency it could only
possibly be made worse by comments from
marjorie taylor greene
i stand by all of my statements i said
nothing wrong
and i think any any rational jewish
person didn't like what happened
in nazi germany and any rational jewish
person
doesn't like what's happening with
overbearing mass mandates
any rational jewish person i'm jewish
i'm not at all religious and thank god
my family made it to this country
decades before the holocaust but that's
my heritage
and i promise you that congresswoman
taylor greene she thinks i'm jewish
so as a rational jewish person let me
just say to marjory taylor green
don't you dare speak for me not if
you're going to compare health measures
or anything
to the holocaust in a tweet last night
she said
i'm sorry if my words make people
uncomfortable no they don't make me
uncomfortable
they make me sick how dare you
abhorrent it makes me sick
i'm a jew myself says john berman sure
uh he doesn't care about his faith he
says and he's never
said a single word of protest against
any left-winger making a holocaust
analogy
ever but even so he is outraged offended
he's never heard of anything so terrible
in his life
and where are the republicans why aren't
they condemning this they must condemn
condemn it once
condemn this thing that we're pretending
to be upset about condemn it
well don't worry republicans are always
ready to bark like dogs whenever the
left snaps its fingers
and right on time house gop leader kevin
mccarthy issued a statement
condemning marjorie taylor green in no
uncertain terms you said in part
uh quote marjorie is wrong and her
intentional decision to compare the
horrors of the holocaust with the with
wearing masks
is appalling the holocaust is the
greatest atrocity committed in history
the fact that this needs to be stated
today is deeply troubling americans must
stand together to defeat anti-semitism
and any attempt to diminish the history
of the holocaust
what a pathetic little worm this guy is
house minority whip uh steve scalise
also condemned
so did liz cheney of course calling the
comments vile and
evil and lunacy
evil it's evil now i mean there are a
lot of evil but everyone on the internet
is evil now
you included everyone
cbs has a report on other gop leaders
who joined in the
condemnation parade quoting now it says
a spokesperson for nancy pelosi
responded that the speaker
quote has for decades spoken out against
anti-semitism and anti-semitic attacks
including just yesterday
citing a tweet from pelosi dancing
against anti-semitism
leader mccarthy waited days to even
issue a statement in response to one of
his members demeaning the holocaust
and a second demeaning the holocaust
oh yeah we wouldn't want to demean and
insult the holocaust
what does that even mean demeaning
the holocaust is a horrific horrible
thing
you wouldn't want to demean it
uh quote and he clearly intends to
continue to welcome marjorie taylor
green in the gop
and shield her from any real
consequences or accountability for her
anti-semitism
uh this according to pelosi spokesperson
drew hamill leader mccarthy's silence
has spoken volumes about his allegiance
to the most extreme elements of the gop
conference
green's recent comments may have
precipitated response from mccarthy
following criticism from prominent
republicans
quote please educate yourself so that
you can realize how absolutely wrong
inappropriate it is to compare proof of
vaccination with the six million jews
who are exterminated by the nazis
you are an embarrassment to yourself and
the gop according to matt brooks the
executive director of the republican
jewish
coalition he said in a tweet on tuesday
morning
jeff miller a prominent gop lobbyist and
close friend of mccarthy
who sits on the holocaust memorial
museum council slammed green in a tweet
on tuesday saying he would be
happy to arrange for her to visit the
u.s holocaust museum quote
then maybe going forward you wouldn't
make any more disgusting ignorant and
offensive tweets
if i'm wrong and you're not ignorant
about the holocaust then you are
disgusting
now you know i could go and and uh and
check to see if any of these blathering
phonies and idiots ever said anything
like this to any democrat who has
invoked the holocaust or hitler
but i don't think i need to check
because we all know the answer they
didn't
we also know that these republicans
being good little puppies and doing as
they're told
will never actually succeed in
satisfying their masters
even though republicans condemned as
they were instructed to and did it
within hours of the offending tweet
still wasn't enough wasn't fast enough
wasn't passionate enough
as wolf blitzer and dana bash back on
cnn
made clear why do you think it took
these republican leaders
so long to condemn these outrageous
comments from this congresswoman
it's a difficult question to answer and
we haven't been able to answer
to ask any of the leaders themselves why
it took them so long
for you and me it's not just political
it's not just the story we're covering
this is a very personal issue given the
fact that both of us
we lost family during the holocaust
that's right and and
none of this should be political this
isn't about political party
this is about right and wrong and and
ignorance
and whitewashing uh something that was a
stain on humanity in in human history
and yeah um i mean the fact that
auschwitz had to come out with this
incredibly powerful tweet
my grandparents were nazi refugees
my great-grandparents perished at
auschwitz
uh yeah you know maybe a yellow star was
something that was
um you know yellow star was horrible
being uh gassed which is what my
great-grandparents
were is a whole different thing and to
compare that to the notion
of public health uh and wearing a mask
is just beyond the pale i can't imagine
what it's like for you wolf
your your parents were in slave labor
camps yeah
the really offensive thing is that these
soulless
sociopaths would use their own dead
family members to score political points
because that's what they're doing here
now if you think i'm being harsh then
please please just show me the clip
from two years ago when wolf blitzer and
dana bash
sat there and tearfully condemned aoc
for accusing trump of running literal
concentration camps
which she did it wasn't even a
comparison she wasn't saying oh it's
like a guy she was saying he actually
has concentration camps
blitzer as a man whose family perished
in real concentration camps must sure
have been
surely have been offended by that if he
was offended by marjorie taylor green's
comments which were
innocuous in comparison but no such clip
or segment exists
and we all know it and that's why
republicans
though they will never stop playing this
game must stop
playing this game what what what the
when the left demands that you condemn
your own side
for doing the things that they do and
saying the things that they
say the correct response is to laugh in
their face
or ignore them if you like or you know
what
outright defend whatever they want you
to condemn purely out of spite
that's fine too because you know really
any response
any response is better than doing as
you're told
and giving them what they want it is not
principle there's no principle here
you are cooperating with these
disingenuous
dishonest frauds taking part in the
charade
allowing yourself to be used emboldening
them
supporting them implicitly or explicitly
and none of that approaches the realm of
principle
maybe you do it out of fear maybe you do
it out of stupidity maybe you do it out
of self-preservation
or maybe you do it because you haven't
thought it through whatever the
motivation it is not the more virtuous
path
if you're an elected republican and you
work with marjorie taylor green
every day and she says something you
disagree with
you can go and speak to her directly
personally i'm not saying you have to
agree with and support everything that
everyone on your side
says and does i'm saying that
condemnation as a public display
as public ritual has to stop
it's the same principle that holds true
for public apologies
i'm against those two i'm not saying
that nobody should ever
apologize ever again i'm not against
apologizing
in principle i'm saying that apologizing
to the public
in this ritualistic fashion because the
mob told you to
is never the right thing
it also will never have the result
you're hoping for
you'll never receive forgiveness through
a public apology
just as you'll never get any credit for
a public condemnation
so stop and grow a backbone
and smarten up please dear god
now let's get to our five headlines
so big news the daily wire has several
open positions for our
in-house team in nashville and this week
we're highlighting the opening for an
accounts payable
associate this person will be
responsible for the day-to-day accounts
payable functions in our finance
department
we're looking for someone with at least
three years of previous professional
accounts payable experience
and familiarity with bookkeeping and
basic accounting procedures are key to
this role
our ideal candidate is also highly
organized and has a strong attention to
detail and i would also add this is just
my own thing
um that if you do come and work here
the garden salsa sun chips in the break
room are for me
and not for anyone else so please leave
those alone
every time i go in there they're gone
that's
anyway forget about that uh this is a
full-time in-office position in
nashville and candidates can apply
through
dailywire.com careers
all right as we get to our um headlines
maybe the number one headline
uh this might be big news to you
celebrity gossip
my wife was out with uh some friends
two nights ago she came home and she
said that she saw tom hanks out here in
nashville like eating
at a restaurant and but then i was kind
of offended because she's telling me
this
and um she wasn't overly impressed which
is good
but she said oh you know it's the first
celebrity that i've seen here
in nashville and i said to her what do
you mean
you see me every day and she paused for
a second and she stared at me blankly
and then burst out laughing in my face
and then she said
i'm gonna tell everyone on twitter you
said that which she did
so not the response you hoped for but uh
that's what it's what it goes that's how
it goes
all right let's go number one this is
from the hill moderna announced on
tuesday
that studies have found that its cova-19
vaccine was 100
effective at stopping infection in
adolescents aged 12 to 17 and that it
planned on submitting the findings to
global regulators
in the coming days 100 effective big
news there
continuing this is from modernist ceo
stephane
bansell uh said in an announcement quote
we're encouraged that the
mrna 1273 was highly effective at
preventing cover 19 in adolescence
it is particularly exciting to see that
modernity
vaccine can prevent the infection we
will
submit these results to the us fda and
regulators globally in early june and
request authorization
according to moderna 3732 participants
age 12 17 were involved in study
no cases of coven 19 were observed in
any of the vaccinated participants
and no significant safety concerns were
identified
um the vaccine was shown to be 93
effective two weeks after the first dose
was administered and 100 effective after
the second dose
according to pharmaceutical company um
so they say that no no
no bad health effects were identified of
course
this study doesn't include
any potential long-term effects one way
or another because it's we
that you have to wait for the long term
to find that out so
um that isn't really known but you know
something to keep in mind here
as we hear about the the the testing
being done with kids
and now the push is really going to
begin
once all this is officially approved for
kids the push is going to
begin to to vaccinate kids for this
and when i say push i mean we can expect
i would imagine
mandates especially if you want your
kids to go to school and that sort of
thing
but one we have to keep in mind we're
told that the vaccine is 100 effective
and what does that mean it means that
these kids were given the vaccine
um and then they didn't contract the
virus
but here's another thing most likely
none of those kids would have gotten the
virus anyway
most likely because do you know what
else is nearly 100
effective in preventing covet infection
in kids 12 to 17 their immune system
their immune system is already almost
100 effective
because covet infections in kids at that
age
is very rare and when it does happen
vast majority of cases extremely mild
what we know this is a statistical fact
kids at that age range are under a
greater threat from the flu
both in terms of the likelihood of
getting affected and the severity of the
illness if they do get infected
than they are from covered that's what
we know
now i have to be careful in how i phrase
all of this
so that youtube doesn't come along and
just shut down the entire show and take
the take the video down
um but everything i've said so far is
statistically correct and so
as parents as these coveted vaccines are
rolled out for kids
and we are quote unquote encouraged to
bring our kids in to get the
the shot we have to we have to think
like okay
i i can inject this substance into my
child
to prevent an illness that they are
nearly certainly not going to contract
already
um or i can just let their immune system
do its thing
and by the way when we talk keep this in
mind too
when we talk about the likelihood
or unlikelihood of kids getting infected
by covid
we're also looking at that's based on
you know statistics and a time period
back when nobody was was vaccinated and
adults weren't vaccinated
and even then when nobody was vaccinated
and uh everybody was potentially
susceptible to the virus
even then kids were hardly getting it
now um
most adults are vaccinated and any adult
who wants to be vaccinated can be
so what are the chances now if all the
adults get vaccinated
or if the vast majority of adults are
either vaccinated or they're
they're immune because of prior
infection
and if even before then kids were
extremely unlikely to get infected by
what are the what are the chances now
that they get infected
it's even less likely it goes from
extremely unlikely to even less than
extremely unlikely
so are you gonna bring your kids in to
get that shot
i would like to know what the scientific
medical case for that is
i don't mean i don't need to hear the
hectoring and all of that
uh i don't i'm not asking for platitudes
or people shouting
give me the scientific medical
data-driven
reason to bring my kids in to get that
shot
given that their immune system is
already nearly 100
effective in preventing the infection
if you can make that case i like to hear
it i'm not sure that you can
alright number two this is from the
daily wire it says earlier this month
two black penn state university
professors reported seeing a noose
in a tree behind their house they told
psu
student newspaper the daily collegian
that the incident was deeply distressing
to them and their family
media outlets media outlet the center
daily times reported that the professors
believe the alleged noose was
deliberately placed on the tree to
harass them
the college fix reported that the patton
township police department found the
noose and began investigating
before that investigation was complete
however psu president eric barron posed
a statement condemning
the alleged act of hate and accepting
the professor's feelings as truth
baron wrote quote the incident
underscores the importance of our
anti-racism work as a university as
a community of scholars it also
underscores the importance of our town
of our um town work to build a safe
welcoming and inclusive environment for
all who live here
when police spoke to professors
neighbors they learn the truth okay so
that's
that's that's this that's the setup and
just to review okay we've got two black
uh university professors
who see quote unquote a noose in a in a
tree behind
what they really saw by the way they saw
a rope they just happened to see a rope
and the immediate assumption now is that
if you're black and you see
a rope anywhere it's
it's it is a suspected noose and someone
planted it there as a hate crime
and so then we had the police
investigating and
the psu president condemning the rope
this is the worst
rope this rope is hateful and bigoted
well it turns out um after police
investigated that um
the rope was not a hate crime it was
part of a swing set
that had been attached to the tree
it was just a swing set which uh you
know
i i don't have we could probably find a
picture of this rope i don't have it in
front of me i'm not sure what it looked
like
um but i'm guessing
first of all what we know is that if it
was if it was part of a swing set it
wasn't an
actual noose
okay it may have been a rope with kind
of like a loop at the end of it
which is where you would attach the
swing but that's not a noose
not every rope that's hanging from
something is a noose
in fact i go this far almost every rope
you know there's no way for me to
confirm this but i'll make this
statement anyway pretty provocative
almost every rope that is currently
hanging from something
in this country right now is not a noose
now you go even further there's a high
likelihood
that none of them are hate crimes
all of the ropes probably thousands and
thousands of ropes currently hanging
from various things
for various reasons and none of them are
hate crimes
because there are so many practical
reasons why human beings hang ropes from
things
one of them is a so i got to wonder
these two
um college professors
you send your kids to be taught by these
people and they've never heard of a
swing set in a tree
they never encounter that in their life
when they were told about the swing set
they said what what do you mean a swing
what
swing what is that
you're saying that children will will
sit on this contraption
and swing back and forth i've never
heard of such a thing
these two poor people i mean they've
been going to playgrounds their entire
lives and thinking that
they're witnessing a clan meeting they
never heard of a swing before
or or you know the other possibility is
that uh
they're not lunatics and they damn well
knew that most likely this rope that
they saw
is has a perfectly innocuous explanation
like a swing
but they decided to run with it anyway
in order to score some victim points
that's the other possibility you know
it's really one of those two
so either they are absolute lunatic
idiots or um
they're just disingenuous frauds you
know to me those are the two most likely
possibilities and i say that again i
haven't seen the rope
i guess every time i see one of these
things i wonder where
we have heard of so many cases of ropes
being mistaken for nooses that were
supposedly
hate crimes including in bubba wallace's
garage
remember there was a there was a garage
door pull someone
it was just a rope used to pull open a
garage
and the fbi what did they said they sent
i think they sent 15 fbi agents to
investigate the rope
so that we've heard of that many other
cases like that
and in every case that we hear about it
turns out that the rope had some
innocuous purpose like a swaying a
garage door pull whatever
crack there was another case in cracker
barrel
it wasn't even a rope it was just a it
was a cord
from like an from like an antique
soldering iron
and it happened to be hanging there and
the assumption was that it was a noose
so a lot of cases like that and they all
turn out to be
fraudulent or hoaxes or
misunderstandings
has where are the real cases of this
does this
ever happen in reality in fact the whole
idea of
a noose as a as a racist
symbol has it ever been a racist symbol
i don't think it has the left just
invented this
it's kind of like the okay side which i
just did right there so you know media
matters is going to be on top of that
the okay sign that you make with the
the the left just decided that this is a
now going to be a
a symbol of hate it never has been
there's no precedent for that they they
just decided it
and they did the same thing with the
noose
yes now it's true that that historically
nooses have been used in murderous and
racist ways that's true
um but going back for thousands of years
ropes and even nooses have had
innocuous uses
and also sometimes murderous uses or
executing people and
oftentimes had nothing to do with race
at all
so the idea that it's now exclusively a
racist symbol where does that come from
it just mainly comes from the media it's
a media invention
all right from the daily wire as a
reporter
reading out says as a reporter discussed
police reform changes since the death of
george floyd at what's now called george
floyd
square gunshots could be heard ringing
out
leaving the reporter to seek cover this
is in minneapolis
philip crowther an international
affiliate reporter for associated press
gms was on scene covering the
anniversary of the floyd arrest
when the gunfire interrupted his
reporting there's just something so
um appropriate i guess about this given
given the context but let's let's watch
the footage now
well look it's not going to be signed in
time at least according to the timeline
that the white house and u.s president
joe biden had
they wanted this bill of comprehensive
police reform
uh to be uh just gotta be careful here
with some gunshots excuse us
it sounds like gunshots i'll let you
know what this is
these seem to be gunshots
uh
uh yeah so it's just a drive-by shooting
at the george floyd memorial to
commemorate the solemn occasion
um not nothing to see there i think the
most
disturbing thing if you watch that
footage
and you have to watch it to appreciate
it so you go to daily wire
or the youtube channel to watch this at
least to watch this segment of it
um it's how you see the reaction from
the people
standing around and they're reacting
like this is something that happens
every day
it wasn't the kind of reaction that you
would expect i saw i think one person
running
a bunch of other people just kind of
standing around almost they might as
well be yawning
almost yawning saying another drive-by
shooting yeah what else what else do you
expect
uh because it why do they act like it
happens every day because it does happen
every day
in minneapolis and in cities across the
country
why does it happen every day well a
large part because these cities are run
by democrats
who have no interest whatsoever
in in preventing crime uh or punishing
the people who commit crime
and it also has something to do we look
at the spike in crime
a massive spike over the last year
well where were they this was
the george floyd memorial
on the anniversary of his death
so we are commemorating his death
like he's a canonized saint like he's a
war hero
he's got a memorial right there so i
wonder can we draw
some connections here
we celebrate and memorialize criminals
bad people who whatever you think about
the circumstances around his death
there was nothing honorable about his
life as far as we know
uh so we celebrate and honor criminals
and then you end up with more crime
could you maybe draw a connection there
if you romanticize excuse and celebrate
criminals and crime is it possible you
end up with more of it i don't know
something to think about
um all right going to the daily mail it
says australian basketball star liz
cambridge has taken to social media to
flaunt her body
after slamming a coach for making
disrespectful comments about her weight
the wnba all-star who plays for the las
vegas aces
i don't have to tell you that right this
is this is liz cambadge we're talking
about
wnba all-star plays for the las vegas
aces
who we all know who this person is we're
all big fans right
here i am giving you details i said liz
cambridge and immediately you thought oh
yeah plays of
nba wnba all-star plays for las vegas
aces
my favorite athlete so excuse me for
explaining who she is i don't mean to
insult your intelligence i know we all
know we're all big wnba fans
um anyway the wnbl a all-star hit back
at connecticut's son
head coach kurt miller after he
encouraged an official to call a foul
against her while saying come on she's
300 pounds
um the six foot eight all-star doubled
down hours later by sharing a video in
the gym showing off her phenomenal
figure while listening to a song
titled big body bends
um all right we don't need to read all
this but we do have a clip of
of who is this again liz cambridge sorry
louise cambridge again big fan um
talking about this
and uh anyway listen to the language
that she uses
so something went down uh in today's
game
and i need to speak on it because if
there's one thing
about me is that i will never let a man
disrespect me
ever ever ever especially a little white
one
go to the coach of connecticut i'm sorry
little sir man
i do not know your name um but
the next time you tried to call out a
referee um you know
trying to get a cold being like come on
she 300 pounds
i'm gonna need you to get it right baby
because i'm six
eight i'm weighing i just double checked
because i love to be correct and get
facts i'm weighing
235 pounds and i'm i'm
very proud of being a big big buddy
big ben's baby um
so don't ever try to disrespect me or
another woman in the league i don't know
if that's how
like coaches run like you just
disrespect you try to disrespect women
like that
from the sideline are you so lucky it
was during a game
that whole part you were so lucky that i
was at my doing my job
so anyway to that little man like
the whole little tiny like where is you
where is you good question she says
she doesn't know who he is i don't know
his name
but which true i don't know his name
either but uh all jokes aside nobody
knows
who you are either liz that's why you're
professional athlete allegedly you make
like forty five thousand dollars a year
because nobody watches and nobody cares
um your entire league is uh
is a basically a welfare program kept
kept afloat by the the nba so
a little bit of humility i think would
be in order
um your league has no right to really
exist because
nobody cares nobody watches it because
it's awful um
and the only reason it does exist is
because the men's league keeps you
afloat
so all i'm saying
that's all to say a little bit of
humility would be nice
is all and i don't need to point out
but i will yet again that she says i
won't let a man disrespect me especially
a little white one
no need to point out that if this was a
white
wnba player talking about a black coach
and said i will never let a man
disrespect me especially a little black
one
this is a whole different conversation
right that
if she had said that that's headline
news everywhere
she's apologizing she's kicked off the
league etc etc and so forth and all of
that we know that's what's going to
happen
but this is just blatant racism from
this woman and uh nobody cares it's
allowed you're allowed to do that
all right but because those are the
rules as we've established totally
different rules depending on who you are
and we're supposed to cooperate with
that
be okay with that in fact um
as we'll talk about the daily
cancellation coming up in just a minute
although that sounds really racist
i'll never let a man disrespect me
especially a little white one
a little white one sounds really racist
but it's not because she can't be racist
it's impossible and we'll talk about
that in the daily cancellation but
before we do
let's get to uh reading the youtube
comments andrew andrew schnick
says matt walsh why do you assume that
the ufos came from space
ever see the movie the abyss maybe the
ufos are from deep in the oceans
i have heard this theory um i like this
theory
the theory to me sounds credible and by
credible i mean it sounds
entertaining and fascinating and i wish
it were true
where can i i've heard this before um
that
maybe the ufos are coming from the ocean
so is there any literature i can i did a
little bit of research
and by research i just mean i googled
ufos in the ocean
and i clicked on the first link that
popped up and i believed everything that
i read
but if anyone has more extensive
research or literature
on uh the issue of ufos coming from the
ocean i'd love to hear are we talking
about
some sort of space portal in the ocean
or
is this a sort of like an atlantis
situation
um aquaman type of thing
where there's a civilization down there
like 98 of the ocean is unexplored we ha
we actually have no idea really what's
happening in the oceans
uh especially at its deepest points so
who knows
but i'll tell you right now i believe it
um let's see another one says
very telling an overweight older man
named trump gets coveted
he puts on a brave face acts like he
feels much better than he does and walks
on his own steam to marine one to the
hospital in back
walks up the balcony and tears his mask
off for all to see aoc was across the
street from where some
unarmed idiots made a ruckus for an hour
she broadcasts her pain and feelings and
need for therapy for the next five
months
ronald reagan was shot can you imagine
him whining about his trauma
or how he needs therapy uh yeah i do
think that's a
a very telling comparison
aoc would tell us women are just as
strong as men
well not saying they aren't but
you're not doing yourself any favors in
making that case
um another one says new
strategy dislike the video when you
start then halfway through
like it the algorithm might think oh
matt really influenced that person
complete 180
double points no no that's that's not
how the algorithm works please don't
don't do that i don't know how you're
getting a little too cute
too smart for your own good just hit
like that's all you have to do hit like
hit like hit it now
um let's see what else
and finally g smith says matt matt
doesn't want women to have facial hair
because he's worried
that one of them might try to rival his
beard
yeah that's not true at all i i
generally am prejudiced against
women who grow out their facial hair
but i would with all that said a woman
who could manage to have
the sort of majestic mane that i do i
would ha i would
i would respect that if you're going to
go for it i guess go all the way it's
what i'm saying
well after a year of lockdown prices
across the country are rising in tandem
with leftist insanity and you're
probably ready to hear some voices of
reason
make a little sense of it so please
throw out your mask and join me jeremy
boring ben shapiro michael knowles and
andrew clavin tonight
for another cigar insanity-packed
episode of backstage by the way
many people have uh said to me that
they're hoping we talk about aliens
tonight on backstage i don't really set
the agenda for the backstage shows but i
will
do my damnedest to make sure that that
subject is brought up um
you i'm i'm in your corner don't worry
it streams tonight at seven o'clock
p.m eastern 6 p.m central on
dailywire.com and on our youtube channel
daily wire you know unlike myself you've
probably never met
candace owens i assume but that might be
about to change if you sign up as a
daily wire member with code vip you'll
get 20
off your new membership and you'll be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios
to see candace live not only will you be
meeting candace but you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio
our office and front row seats to watch
her live and in action on her talk show
canvas so don't wait go enter to win
a canvas vip pass now at dailywire.com
subscribe
using code vip for 20 off now let's get
to our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation today we must
confront the perhaps counterintuitive
and even disturbing idea that just
because someone is writing stuff on a
whiteboard
that doesn't mean they're right i know
this could seem confusing at first it's
sort of like how we all assume that
anyone holding a clipboard must be a
trustworthy
authority figure anyone in a lab coat
must be
an expert on science and medicine anyone
wearing a yellow vest
must have the authority to stop and
redirect traffic
any man with a beard must be able to
defeat a grizzly bear in close quarters
combat
that last one is actually true but the
rest are often incorrect assumptions
as evidenced by the target of our
cancellation today
this is a man who goes by the handle
jolly good ginger
and here he is in a recent viral video
standing in front of a white board
explaining why white people can never be
the victims of racism
and he is white himself we must
acknowledge lots of people find this
kind of reasoning convincing
i'm not as convinced but let's let's
give it a listen
this is a question i get asked a lot can
white people
experience racism in america first let's
understand the word
racism it ends with ism
much like capitalism the same
ism communism the same ism
socialism the same ism so what does that
ism mean ism means a system put in place
by those in power
centered around a specific set of ideas
for example
capitalism a system put in place by
those in power
centered around capitalist ideas
communism is a system put in place by
those in power centered around
communist ideas socialism is a system
put in place by those in power centered
around socialist ideas so what is
racism it's a system put in place by
those in power
centered around racist ideas
okay let's pause there just for a moment
um ism
means a system put in place by those in
power he says
huh well maybe he's he's right i mean he
did give us like four examples
but then what about i don't know
transgenderism
is transgenderism a system put in place
by those in power well come to think of
it it sort of is
but what about existentialism
romanticism hypothyroidism is a person's
dysfunctional thyroid gland really a
system put in place
by those in power what about lesbianism
narcissism romanticism surrealism
witticism fatalism eroticism masochism
hypnotism
deism atheism it turns out there are
literally hundreds of ism words
and the vast majority of them don't fit
with the definition
that the jolly ginger has provided i
never thought i'd see the day when a
ginger would prove himself
untrustworthy i'm just kidding we see
those all the time never trust them
as it turns out the suffix ism does not
mean a system put in place by those in
power
it can mean that that that could be one
potential usage for the term
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
what ism actually signifies is a system
or theory or principle or process or
action so then what is racism
well racism is a theory that one race is
inferior to your own
it's also a principle a bad one but a
principle um
it's even an action racism can be a lot
of things that manifest itself in a lot
of ways
and white people can certainly be the
victims of it
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
jolly ginger has more to say let's uh
keep listening so then can white people
experience racism
what you're saying is when somebody says
to you cracker honky
i don't trust white people colonizer
white
devil that you're experiencing racism
well you're not
let me explain what you're experiencing
is called
prejudice prejudice is when someone has
an
idea about you based purely on the way
you look
the reason that's not racism is this the
black community
is incarcerated at a rate three times
higher than white people for the same
crime
are shot by the police at a rate three
times higher than
white people a traditional black name on
a resume will receive a callback
five times less commonly than a
traditional white name
white people are not victims of racial
profiling redlining gentrification
you see the system targeting
marginalized communities
is racism so even though a white person
may experience
prejudice they'll never have to worry
about being targeted by the entire
system
and that's what racism is and racism is
much worse
than prejudice that was all a bunch of
stupid
bull crap let me explain i i turned on
my own whiteboard now but i don't have
one and besides frankly
his choice of a whiteboard instead of a
blackboard is pretty racist
in and of itself he says that the reason
a racist comment against white people
isn't racist is because black people are
incarcerated at a higher rate than white
people
this is what we call a non-sequitur
i would ask him to put that on the board
but i doubt he can spell it
it's hard to even debunk the argument or
or engage with it because it simply
makes no sense
it would be like if i if i slapped you
in the face and you said hey you slapped
me in the face and i said
no i didn't my dog died last tuesday
the fact that my dog died in no way
proves that i didn't slap you in the
face
it also doesn't justify it as you
personally were not the one who killed
my dog
is it true that black people are
incarcerated at a higher rate yes it's
also true that they commit
crimes at a higher rate statistically so
to prove that the higher incarceration
rate is the result of racism you'd have
to prove
that actually whites commit the same
amount of crime or more crime
and are let off the hook or else that
black people are in the majority of
cases incarcerated for things they
didn't do
now if you could prove that then you'd
have a case that
that's an example of systemic racism and
if you can prove it go ahead but you'll
need a lot more
than a dry erase marker and a white
board to do it and anyway
all that aside none of that has anything
to do
with the definition of racism he's also
wrong about white people never
experiencing systemic prejudice
they do all the time affirmative action
is one obvious and an irrefutable
example
that is a system put in place by those
in power
which is directly and explicitly
prejudiced
against white people especially white
males
no denying it by his definition that's
systemic racism
but again all that's really beside the
point racism is not distinct from
prejudice
these aren't two different things racism
is but one
form of prejudice saying that's not
racism it's prejudice is like saying
that's not an elephant it's a mammal
another non-sequitur
racism in reality is prejudice
discrimination or antagonism directed
against someone of a different race
based on the belief
that one's own race is superior
that's racism the wnba player
talking about that little white one
that's racism
okay that's what racism is that's always
been racism
that's what the words always meant jolly
ginger here is is going with a different
definition he's using
the racism is prejudice plus power
formulation which you've probably heard
before and it's the basis for critical
race theory
the problem with that definition is that
first of all it assumes wrongly that
black people have no power
an utterly ridiculous claim in a country
that just elected elected a black
president twice
but more importantly the definition is
straightforwardly false
do you know where it comes from well it
we know who it
comes from an act from a from a specific
person it was made up by a sociologist
named patricia by patricia baidal in the
1970s
she came along and decided that racism
would mean this other thing now and
people like jolly ginger have decided
that patricia baidal
is the sole and unquestioned authority
on this subject
so when the jolly ginger and his ilk
give this definition
what they should say is not you know
racism is
power plus prejudice but what they
should say is you know patricia baidal
says racism is power
plus prejudice to which we can respond
who the k who the hell is she and who
cares what she says
that's exactly like if i said that the
new definition of cold
is the condition of being warm
and you asked me to explain how i
arrived at that conclusion and i said
well
um this guy bill jenkins told me
who's bill jenkins why should his
opinion matter
who imbued bill jenkins with the
god-like powers to
redefine entire concepts with the flick
of his magic wand well it doesn't matter
bill jenkins decided this and now that's
it just as patricia decided that black
people can't be racist
and so that means black people can't be
racist
this is all quite nonsensical of course
it's the very definition of ad hoc
reasoning
ad hoc reasoning is when an answer
solution definition or argument
is invented out of the blue in order to
achieve some particular
end or to justify some specific claim
now the great thing about the ad hoc
approach is that you can keep changing
it you keep adjusting it
as your rhetorical or ideological needs
require
which is what these people do they keep
kind of
you know tinkering with the definition
of racism
with the specific aim of making sure
that uh whatever happens no black person
can be guilty of it and only white
people can be guilty of it
that's ad hoc that's what it means at
least that's what ad hoc used to mean i
guess we'll have to check with patricia
baidal to see
if it still means that because she's the
one who decides these things
this of course is the leftist mo to try
and win arguments by summarily
changing what words mean the change is
never justified or explained it's simply
asserted
and we're all meant to be quiet and go
along with it
unfortunately i'm not that cooperative
so i must still insist
that racism means what it means and has
always meant
regardless of what some sociologist and
some red-headed guy with a white board
have to say
and that is why our jolly ginger friend
today is sadly
canceled and we'll leave it there thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show on the one year
commemoration of george floyd's death
more black people are dying and not at
the hands of the cops but
the media are super happy at all of
racial progress that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen